why
so as we get back into the habit of
making Marvel comic videos as we get
back into this sort of mindset what
we're going to do is we're going to kind
of take a break from the status quo that
we've created so far but only for this
video instead of making you guys wait
until Monday to do Civil War issue
number four we're going to go ahead and
and really add this video to our tie-in
Thursday series of videos and the reason
for this is because one there are no
tie-ins between civil war issue number
three and issue number four that was
something I had previously met spoke
about but the other reason for this is
because you all have been extremely
patient while I've taken my break and so
rather than making you guys wait until
Monday for Civil War issue number four
and then making you wait until Thursday
for the tie-ins for issue issue number
four Civil War I figure we go ahead and
do these on a Thursday and Monday so on
Thursday we'll do Civil War issue number
four and we'll do these the tie-ins and
then on Monday we'll finish up the times
and then do Civil War issue number five
so what we see as the story begins to
unfold is that again Thor has arrived at
the chemical plant where Captain America
and Iron Man's forces are fighting and
virtually everyone is surprised to see
him or the very least everyone on the
side of Captain America and we see
individuals like Falcon and Ned and
dagger really kind of shocked and dagger
goes as far as to say that they thought
Thor had been killed but right off the
bat Thor is really kind of acting
uncharacteristic and states that dagger
is you want to be the one that gets
killed which is not something that Thor
normally says in addition we see Thor
begin to attack Captain America's forces
with relentless fashion and again this
is uncharacteristic and the reason for
this is because some of Captain
America's forces are friends of Thor and
Thor is not one to arbitrarily attack
his friends without question now as we
begin to see his attack continuing on
Captain America's forces dagger really
kind of panics and says that they need
to get out of here that something is
extremely wrong but again the Thor
continues his attack on Captain
America's team now from this point we
switch to Captain America and Iron Man
and what's really kind of interesting
here is that Ironman is offering aid
Captain America he's telling Captain
America they will give him medical
treatment if you'll just surrender now
the way they Captain America really kind
of reacts to this is very important and
I would like you guys to pay very
particular attention to this and the
reason why is because Captain America is
really kind of an extremist now he is so
ingrained in his idea that
anti-registration is the way to go that
the Registration Act is so wrong and so
against freedom that he's unwilling to
accept any opinion other than his own
and this is very uncharacteristic of
Captain America because throughout all
of Captain America's publication history
he's been a very reasonable person while
there may be ideas that are different
than his while he may be walking a
certain Road he's always willing to
listen to other opinions he's always
willing to listen to what other people
say but we don't see that happening here
and so because Captain America is so
entrenched because he is so unwilling to
give up
iron man activates a kind of sonic pulse
in his armor which really kind of causes
excruciating pain and the minds of all
of Captain America's forces and really
kind of puts them in a place where they
were unable to continue fighting but
what we see is that Captain America is
really able to withstand the sonic pulse
and Iron Man really kind of gives him
credit for it and as iron man is
beginning to deal the final blow to
knock out Captain America Hercules comes
to the rescue of Captain America and by
virtue of throwing a tanker at Iron Man
disables the sonic pulse that had been
rendering Captain America's forces
unable to fight from there the conflict
begins again and everybody begins
fighting each other once more in
addition we see that as Hercules is
engaging Iron Man he calls for Falcon to
rescue Captain America which Falcon
successfully does and of course Falcon
tells cable that he needs to interface
with cloaks mind so that they can
activate a teleport and get everybody
out of there in addition what we see is
Goliath confronting Thor now this is an
extremely important part of civil war
and the reason why is because what we
see is that Thor kills Goliath now this
is an extremely important thing and the
whole reason why this is so important is
for several reasons the first is that
Thor and Bill Foster Goliath were very
close friends and Thor attacks him and
kills him without
question and so right off the bat we
know that if there were any other kind
of indication that something's not right
or this isn't actually Thor this really
kind of solidified it that there's no
way that this is actually Thor or if it
is Thor his mind has somehow been warped
or his mind has somehow been screwed up
so that he doesn't know who his friends
are and what we see as a result of
Goliath being killed is that virtually
all heads turn everyone is wildly
surprised to see this Captain America's
forces Captain America's forces I'm
sorry Iron Man's forces and Captain
America's forces shields forces
everybody is really kind of surprised to
see this happen and because Thor has
gone to such an extreme degree and
killed someone all of Captain America's
forces go into panic mode and everybody
extremes or everybody demands that they
retreat in order to get out of there to
keep from being killed in addition we
see Thor continues his assault on
Captain America's forces but Susan storm
comes to their rescue creating a force
field around them that no one can enter
and really tells them to get out of
there to get to safety
in addition we see that a falcon really
kind of thinks her for her effort that
that everything is really kind of not
going the way that anyone had expected
it to in addition they asked about the
wounded individuals who were part of
Captain America's forces who have been
injured are they going to leave them
behind of course kibble replies that
you're welcome to stay if you want to
but the best shot for all of them is to
get out while they can which they
successfully do using the teleportation
capabilities of cloak now what we see is
an indication that of course this is not
Thor when read Richard Reed Richards
uses a kind of code to shut down Thor
now from this point everybody starts
screaming at Reed Richards Hank Pym
yells Adams says that he thought that
there was some kind of directives that
were installed and Thor to keep him from
doing what it was that he did in
addition we see the Sue Storm really
kind of turns are back on Reed Richards
and this is really kind of interesting
here because while the Fantastic Four
really kind of achieved their popularity
due to the fact that they would have
family and fighting and they were really
kind of the real-life version of what
you would expect to see in a family this
is really an instance where it's
entirely possible that Reed Richards and
Susan storm could split up because this
kind of
a so extreme that it was something that
no one saw coming it was a severe and
fatal mistake on behalf of Reed Richards
in addition we see that Spider Man
really kind of begins to question Tony
Stark that he says it he thought Tony
Stark knew what they were knew what he
was doing that this kind of plan was
implemented to ensure that nobody got
hurt and this is really kind of one of
the very baby steps one of the very
first steps that we see with regards to
spider-man questioning Iron Man and as
we'll see an amazing spider-man issue
number 534 he begins to really kind of
continue down this path then one of the
final panels that we see in this aspect
as part of the comic is The Watcher
who's really kind of monitoring these
events and again this is important
because the watcher only really appears
in times of great social upheaval or in
times when an event is about to take
place or taking place that could
drastically change the landscape of
whatever it is that he happens to be
looking at at that particular point in
time from here we switch to Avengers
Tower and we see that Iron Man's forces
are really kind of recuperating that
they're really kind of I guess maybe
recovering from their injuries and we
see of course that Reed Richards is
working on the mechanical clone of Thor
and this is when we learned that Thor is
actually a machine this not is this is
not in fact Thor in addition we see that
Hank Pym is really kind of distraught to
see that one of his oldest friends
Goliath had been killed because Goliath
was an individual that Hank Pym had
really not necessarily lent his Pym
particles to but had really kind of
confronted on several occasions and it
really kind of instructed on how to use
the Pym particles adequately so that
Goliath bill foster could actually turn
into giant man whenever it was that he
wanted to in addition what we see is
that you know Peter Parker really kind
of tells I guess ant-man's wife Jen Van
Dyne that this really wasn't something
they signed up for that this is really
kind of freaky and that no one really
wanted to be part of a group that was
willing to go to the extremes of killing
people in order to make sure that their
their plans came to fruition in addition
you know Hank Pym really kind of asked
the question why is it that this
happened what happened with Thor you
know that Tony Stark had been holding on
to a hair of Thor's for quite some time
that's what they used to clone him and
that maybe it was the fact that they
didn't instill a conscience in him there
was really no human element to Thor that
would really kind of keep him from
flipping out the way he did and killing
people and in one of the interesting
parts one of the more important parts
when it comes to Peter Parker is when we
see cm ask aunt Pam whether or not that
they think they've joined the right side
now from here we switched to Captain
America's headquarters where his team
has really kind of recovered to where
they've kind of retreated to and again
this is extremely important when it
comes to Captain America and the reason
why is because Captain America has
really kind of adopted this by any means
necessary attitude meaning that he's
really not very remorseful about the
fact that Goliath had been killed he the
only thing he really cares about at this
point is that they win and again this is
very uncharacteristic of Captain America
and as he's talking with Nighthawk you
know he's really kind of saying that
they're gaining more supporters from
Tony Stark's side by the hour and it's
really the only concern that he has and
what we see with Nighthawk is that he's
just really not willing to go along with
this if he's really not okay with this
kind of attitude that Captain America
has adopted where he's disassociated
himself from caring about members of his
team and only really cares about winning
the fight with Iron Man and what we
ultimately see is really kind of
splitting up a various individuals we
see people really kind of leaving
Captain America's team for several
reasons of course we see that a cassie
one of the individuals who's part of
Captain America's team leaves because
she sees the extreme lengths that I
guess Iron Man and his team are willing
to go to to win their fight that they
are actually willing to allow someone to
kill people which of course we know
wasn't the intention but they don't know
that in addition we see that some
individuals are leaving because they
don't want to go to jail they don't want
to have to worry about being captured
and sent to whatever kind of location it
is they are taking every superhero who
has been captured for refusing to
register and what we see here is a
really kind of everybody bailing out we
really kind of see everybody leaving and
taking off and as we really kind of
begin to come to an end with regards to
the view of Captain America at their
secret hideout we see someone who is
really kind of watching these events on
full
from the shadows now this is very
important especially when we when it
comes towards the end and the events
after Civil War completely closes out as
part of a major Marvel event now from
here we switch to the funeral of Goliath
and the funeral of Goliath is really
kind of a chance for us to see Tony
Stark you know for what he is to really
kind of look at Tony Stark going to say
you know there's still a chance that
Tony Stark isn't necessarily a bad guy
that he did not intend for Bill Foster
to be killed and he really kind of shows
his remorse in the sense that because
Bill Foster was killed while he was
still as a giant they didn't really it
didn't really offer the opportunity for
his body to shrink down and so 37 burial
plots had to be purchased by Tony Stark
in order for him to be buried and of
course Tony Stark said that he did this
simply because it was the least that he
could do for the family of Bill Foster
in addition what we also see is that
miss Sharpe who was the mother of one of
the children that was killed at the
beginning of civil war if you recall she
had spat at Tony Stark approaches him
and of course tells him that she's not
going to accost him and that she thinks
he's doing the right thing that Goliath
knew what he was doing that he knew that
he was breaking the law and that this
was a very real possibility when he
really kind of set down the path that he
was going on and that this really isn't
anybody's fault except goliaths what we
also see is kind of a I guess coming but
panel montage of sorts where we see that
Susan storm has written a letter to Reed
Richards telling him that that Johnny's
out of the hospital that the family's
going to be back together again soon
that she should be happy about this but
she's not and the reason why is because
she's so ashamed of what Reed Richards
has done she's ashamed of the fact that
Reed Richards
had effectively alongside captain I'm
sorry along staad iron man and Hank Pym
created a hero created a clone that
really killed people that had gone to
such a degree that it really had no
conscience and was so violent you know
she really is is kind of telling him
that you know the hands of everybody who
was on the side of Captain or arms on
the side of iron man is soaked in blood
that Bill Foster's blood is on their
hands and what we see is that she's
really kind of leaving Reed
Richards and leaving Ironman side to
join the side of Captain America now
from here we switch back to Avengers
Tower and what we see is that ant-man
Reed Richards Tony Stark and Jan Van
Dyne are really kind of talking about
the fifty state initiative that the
fifty state initiative is this idea of
having a superhero team in every state
and that Thor is actually not the only
one of its kind that was created by Hank
Pym Reed Richards and Tony Stark that
there are other superheroes who have
been created that way but they're simply
just not ready for combat and we see of
course that Reed Richards has assembled
a new group of Thunderbolts now the
reason for this is because the previous
group of Thunderbolts led by Baron Hill
musi Moe had previously been disbanded
due to a set of events that took place
outside the events of civil war which we
won't go into but the new group of
Thunderbolts that have been assembled
consists of some very nasty villains
which include Lady Deathstrike
and venom and so this is again an
instance where we see that that Iron Man
has really just not learned from his
mistakes we see that they're taking
precautions to really kind of provide
computer chips for these individuals to
ensure that they stay in compliance with
the rules that have been laid down for
them and that they will be put back in
jail immediately after their services
are no longer needed but again we really
kind of see that Tony Stark while his
heart may be in the right place while he
believes that superhuman registration
may very well be the rest best road to
take that he's making all the wrong
decisions to ensure that superhuman
Registration actually goes through with
that being said I'm going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys later